so with states across the country well
into phased reopening plans public
health experts now fear massive protests
could spark new coronavirus outbreaks
due to the close proximity of so many
demonstrators Claudia Cowan is live in
the San Francisco Bay Area with more
Claudia that's right or tell it's a
legitimate concern when you look at the
pictures and consider there is virtually
no social distancing and very few people
are wearing masks add to that smoke from
fires and tear gas which makes people
cough you've got a deadly recipe there
for possible new infections but many
protesters don't care others say they
have no choice Spence Ingram a black
woman in Atlanta who marched to the
State Capitol on Friday said quote it's
not okay that in the middle of a
pandemic we have to be out here risking
our lives but I have to protect for my
protest for my life and fight for my
life all the time the mayor of Atlanta
is urging demonstrators to get a kovat
test this week health experts worry that
silent carriers of the virus who don't
show any symptoms may be infecting
others without realizing it in Minnesota
the epicenter of the violence officials
had this message we are still in the
middle of a pandemic and passed a
thousand deaths yesterday we still have
hospitals on the verge of being overrun
with kovat 19:00 we're in the middle of
a pandemic right now we have two crises
that are sandwiched on top of one
another it's also an issue from paris to
hong kong where anti-government leaders
accused police of using social
distancing rules to break up protests
there are now more than six million
confirmed cases of kovat 19 around the
world more than 300 67,000 have died
including 103 thousand people here in
the u.s which has more than 1,700 cases
overall deaths here in the United States
are trending down slowly but a couple of
states are still fighting to level off
in terms of new cases including Arizona
South Carolina and here in California
where the numbers have been going up for
a few weeks now
even as the Golden State prepares to
reopen more of its economy starting
tomorrow Arthur
Claudia Colwyn thank you